let me go next to our caller from the
2:01 area code who's calling today from
two zero one
hey David this is Mickey from New Jersey
hey Mickey what's up so man first of all
I just wanted to say that someone who in
2016 voted for Bernie and has actually
been following his career from anyway
before any of them became popular could
I used to be like probably further to
the listener than you honestly at one
point I've noticed though as I've gotten
older and this is about pretty classic
with many people who get older you
become a little bit more conservative
and I've started you know really
considering all hi idea and at the same
time in 2016 I've noticed that the
progressive left is just actually like
they're just becoming way more extreme
quite frankly I'm an israeli-american
net like Adam is also a Zionist I've
been to so many times it's almost like
you tell people that you're Israeli and
they just assumed the worst in you now I
see how I just saw the video some do
some in mom cuz Eenie he literally just
said oh I'm gonna vote for Bernie even
though he's a Jew and that's totally
fine today like I don't think that would
ever have been acceptable four years ago
so I guess my point is do you think that
the problem is Bernie it's probably not
true but do you think that any of this
like just extreme dislike hyper purity
this whole like oh we're better than you
we know what's good and what's bad and
if you're bad we don't even want to talk
to you because we there's no point of
like engaging with Nazis whatever they
think if you think any of that has to do
with the failures of the Bernie Sanders
movement or is that just like has
nothing to do with anything so yeah I
mean listen earlier this earlier this
week I outlined this there were three
main problems with Bernie's campaign and
all three I've been talking about for
four years problem number one is that a
lot of the policies that people like
that who are in Bernie's circle are far
less popular among all Democrats so even
Medicare for all is less popular among
all Democrats and so a lot of Democrats
who vote in the primary just didn't want
to vote for Bernie Sanders that that's
one thing and that that was
underestimated number two the democratic
socialist revolution stuff
did not help Bernie Sanders again it's
really great for rallies but as we know
rallies don't win you elections it's
really great for Twitter and reddit but
once again I've been saying for at this
point it's five years I don't think
there was any benefit for Bernie calling
himself a Democratic Socialist and
talking about revolution and then number
three is you're pointing out Bernie has
a lot of toxic people around him
including that Imam from Sunday night in
Dearborn which we talked about and and
other people so if I had to say what are
the the real failings there it's not
necessarily the issues although some of
the issues are actually less popular
than maybe we think when we look at
Twitter and reddit I think it's all
three of those things put together so
then the question is really why is he
embracing like what benefit does Bernie
at least see as someone who I think
historically used to be much more
reasonable like someone who before he
became super famous you you see that
he's always using Congress like you're
obviously talking to people so there I
disagree with you Mickey I don't think
Bernie's gotten any more radical I don't
even describe him as radical if you look
at his policies I think there's just
nothing to gain from using the language
of I'm a Democratic Socialist and we
need a revolution I think that's a
strategic mistake I don't actually think
Bernie's any more radical today than he
ever was so then why is he embraced what
benefit is he getting from embracing
like to leave and Iran Omar who were
just like you know she's to leave now
does war shirt that basically put the
entire Palestinian eradicated Israel
which is like the biggest fear of all
Israelis is that the Palestinians want
to get rid of us oh I know that but then
she wears the shirt literally all
Palestine Muslim symbols all over the
shirt and like you know with a thumbs up
in the picture and it's like well this
is what we've been telling you that they
want to destroy our country so then when
we were act kind of like you know maybe
we irrationally respond with extreme
violence okay I understand
and then today our fears are justified
listen I don't know I know I know very
little about rafita Talib I don't know
what Bernie's calculation is for having
her around I can only go by what Bernie
says on the issue of the
israeli-palestinian conflict which is
Israel has both
to exist and to defend itself period and
we need to work on improving the
situation for Palestinians as well and
I'm behind that position
you know the Talib stuff or or whatever
else you know I I know less about but I
think it's important making you're kind
of mixing a lot of different things
together it's important to look at each
of these things one by one all right
interesting
okay so you don't think is a really a
connection there all right it's not that
these things aren't connected it's like
that in the way that you're asking me
I'm not I'm not sure I have any other
answer other than to go to what Bernie
is saying if that makes sense okay
interesting okay all right Mickey thank
you for the call very much appreciate
hearing from you that is going to do it
for calls today sorry I wasn't able to
pick up on everybody we will take calls
again and I will hear from more folks
next time one of our sponsors today is
VIN Chara watches giving you 15% off
your entire order when you go to david
pakman.com slash watch don't pay
thousands of dollars for a high-quality
watch that looks great because you don't
have to all of in Cera's watches are
made with high-end materials masterfully
built and they look like something you'd
spend a ton of money on but ever even
chero watch ranges from about a hundred
and fifty to three hundred bucks I went
over to their website and picked out the
bellwether in silver and white really
nice elegant look it's a coronagraph
style wore it to a gala over the weekend
and a lot of people ask me where's the
watch from really really great look
totally different they also sent me the
altitude in matte black and red a much
more rugged view of what a watch can
look like really liked it as well as
well as the athletic strap it's a new
year it's a new decade it's time to
re-establish your style add something
new to your look and a high quality
watch is the perfect way to do that you
can get 15% off inch arrows entire
collection when you go to david
pakman.com slash watch